con un claro acento proselitista de Cara
a las elecciones del próximo 2 de
octubre el presidente de Brasil y Air
bolsonaro encabeza este miércoles los
festejos por El bicentenario de la
independencia del país de Portugal tanto
el mandatario como los grupos de
ultraderecha que respaldan a su gobierno
han convocado actos en apoyo a su
candidatura a la reelección amenazada
por el ex presidente Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva favorito para imponerse en los
comicios celebraremos los 200 años de
nuestra independencia y nuestra Sagrada
libertad estaré en Brasilia por la
mañana y en Río de Janeiro por la tarde
les pido a todos que vengan para que
podamos hacer una gran fiesta y expresar
nuestro amor por Brasil esta
convocatoria fue mal recibida por su
contrincante quien considera que el
actual jefe de estado del país
suramericano está usando El bicentenario
para hacer campaña
bolsonaro está usurpando el 7 de
septiembre para hacer algo personal
podría haber tenido la grandeza de hacer
una fiesta para el pueblo brasileño pero
no para su propio beneficio el acto
institucional será celebrado en la
Explanada de los ministerios una venida
de Brasilia que concentra a todos los
edificios del poder público nacional se
realizará un desfile Cívico militar para
el que las autoridades de Brasilia
esperan un Público de unas 40.000
personas entre ellos el presidente de
Portugal así como autoridades de Angola
cabo verde Guinea bizahui mozambique que
también fueron colonias portuguesas